eu vou contar uma pequena história de
algumas iniciativas de inovação do oeste
e vou juntar um pouco com a minha
história durante esses últimos quatro
anos o que foi falado brevemente
eu estou lá trabalhando como diretor de
inovação
agora eu queria contar que o suco
compartilhar meu sofrimento com vocês
imagine você nunca ter trabalhado na
área da saúde e de repente você vai
assumir a diretoria de inovação de um
hospital do porte do oeste e você começa
a pensar o que eu vou fazer aqui sofrer
um pouco com a ansiedade
então o máximo que eu conhecia esse
hospital por meus três filhos nasceram
lá mas de fato quando você começa a
olhar o que a gente pode fazer de
diferente
nesse cenário a pergunta é o que está
mudando hoje foi um dia excepcional o
que aconteceu aqui a gente viu muitos
empreendedores certo que mais que a
gente viu muita tecnologia nova é um
pouco dessa história que vou contar pra
vocês como que de uma certa maneira a
gente pode olhar os empreendedores gente
que às vezes está cometendo um sonho tem
uma idéia é ter um protótipo e quer
transformar a saúde como einstein pode
atuar nessas nessa situação
o fato é o seguinte existe uma revolução
em curso tecnológica
por mais que a gente possa assim é todo
dia e para o trabalho
e parece que nada mudou você chegar lá
se você trabalha no hospital tem
paciente tem o exame tem diagnóstico mas
que nada mudou
mas por trás tem uma revolução o celular
smartphone só tem 10 anos 11 anos na
verdade olho que mudou a sociedade
será que ele vai mudar saúde será que
cada um da sua casa
ou de qualquer lugar onde você esteja
vai poder ter acesso ao médico o que
isso significa em termos acesso à saúde
o que significa esse monte de dados
estão sendo coletados que antes não eram
coletados a teve uma apresentação
recente aqui que falou de de prontuário
eletrônico e coisas dessa natureza no
brasil apenas 20% dos hospitais são
digitalizados não há dados nos estados
unidos chegou a 100 por cento mas há dez
anos atrás estados unidos também era 20%
então existe está em curso uma revolução
de dados na área da saúde
isso pode ter grandes implicações outra
coisa robótica robótica é uma coisa
bacana todo mundo gosta de ver o
robozinho né
mas quantos milhares de pessoas já foram
passaram por uma cirurgia via robôs o
número bem grande mas tem foram milhares
vocês conseguem imaginar cenário não sei
se já viram isso mas é basicamente um
médico operando como se fosse um
videogame e pinças a distância fazendo
uma cirurgia uma pessoa como é que vai
ser daqui 10 anos daqui a 20 anos
também tivemos aqui o quinto falando de
forma genética 15 milhões de pessoas
foram seqüenciados nos estados unidos
hoje existe um esforço brutal das
sociedades médicas e correlacionar o seu
dna há uma série de conseqüências para
sua saúde ea indigitação no começo dá
uma idéia do que é isso
há cerca de 15 anos atrás o primeiro
seqüenciamento de uma pessoa custou
cerca de 3 bilhões de dólares
quanto custa hoje cerca de 100 dólares 6
entende começam a refletir o impacto
disso na saúde
bom a gente olhou tudo isso e olhou todo
esses empreendedores ea perguntar o que
o einstein poderia fazer uma das grandes
lições de saúde do país
e essa parede aí na verdade a foto de
uma parede que a gente colocou o nosso
portal de inovação a gente olhou para o
cenário falou a gente pode pensar grande
a gente pode pensar não dos pacientes do
einstein
a gente pode pensar em como desenvolver
soluções e apoiar soluções que estão
sendo desenvolvidas no brasil todo
nós olhamos e conversamos com mais de
mil está tapes de saúde nos últimos
quatro anos nós recebemos conversamos
discutimos estamos fazendo parcerias com
um monte delas inclusive vários que se
apresentarão o jec também imaginamos que
as coisas podem ser muito mais rápidas
eu me lembro quando comecei a trabalhar
na área da saúde
algumas pessoas falaram terra você não
sabe nada da saúde é tudo mais lento mas
a gente falou dá pra acreditar que dá
para ser muito mais rápido e aí foi
criado um laboratório de inovação nós
entre outras coisas
este laboratório de inovação quem no
oratório onde tem pessoas que acreditam
que as coisas podem ser feitas de outra
maneira de maneira muito mais rápida
muito mais efetiva
muitas vezes na tecnologia não é nada
como tratamento humano fato o seguinte a
tecnologia que permite escala que
permite atender pessoas permite
democratizar o acesso ao diagnóstico o
tratamento o que a gente faz uma série
de produtos
eu vou dar alguns exemplos para vocês
uma escala médica alguém que trabalha no
hospital
cada médico é um problema gigante e uma
das perguntas que a gente tinha é que se
a gente resolveu escala médica no haiti
desde resolve de outros hospitais sim
desenvolvemos um produto chamado escala
que hoje rodam em centenas de hospitais
no brasil ea partir de genética
será que o que a genética senão uma
análise de bancos de dados cada vez mais
sofisticadas utilizando a inteligência
artificial e quem está fazendo isso
olha essa foto porque vocês estão vendo
cinco rapazes que estão transformando a
saúde junto com os médicos do einstein
engenheiros da da usp do ita que
resolveram trabalhar na área da saúde é
um pouco científica formação que eu tô
passando pra vocês aqui mas ela diz o
seguinte é capaz de desenvolver um robô
de inteligência artificial capaz de
diagnosticar o câncer de próstata como
eficiência tão alta como os melhores
médicos na especialidade se consegue
imaginar o impacto disso a tecnologia
ela está vindo mesmo dia seguinte à área
da saúde talvez seja a área que vai ser
mais impactadas pela revolução
tecnológica que está acontecendo em
mobile permite sina robótica
inteligência artificial e de novo assim
vocês estão vendo isso aqui
provavelmente alguns de vocês vão voltar
para o trabalho na segunda feira parece
que nada mudou
tem uma revolução em curso ea gente
aposta nisso nós mas tudo se faz com
talentos
quem são esses talentos são jovens
jovens como os vários que apresentaram
que não jovens apenas de idade jovens de
espírito que realmente acreditam que dá
pra pensar grande e as soluções não
podem ser pequenas ea tecnologia que
permite pensar muito grande pensar com
escala sempre com o propósito de
melhorar a vida das pessoas fazendo
cocriação fazer protótipos usabilidade
escalabilidade de onde vêm essas
tecnologias do mundo da tecnologia vem
do mundo do vale do silício
será que esse mundo tem a ver com a área
da saúde a gente acredita que sim
acredita também que tem a partir de uma
coisa fundamental chamada
empreendedorismo que toda essa
tecnologia ela não vai fazer nada se não
tiver empreendedores voltados para
melhorar a vida das pessoas
empreendedores sociais empreendedores de
alto impacto
empreendedores que a partir de uma ideia
identificação de um problema por
resolver a saúde
e aí várias as empresas que vocês viram
hoje se apresentar aqui são empresas que
contam com uma grande parceria com as
têm a gente acredita que eles fazem
diferença não apenas os jovens talentos
que a gente tá apoiando lá dentro
o toque de inovação mas esses
empreendedores que a gente faz com eles
atualmente a gente faz protótipo a gente
testa de pesquisa clínica apoio do
laboratório de inovação
vamos acesso a todos os equipamentos e
de laboratórios do einstein
também investimos de repente um hospital
filantrópico começou a investir pra
valer e startup empreendedores porque a
gente acredita que eles são mais rápidos
eles pensam de maneira a não óbvia eles
estão a fim de transformar o país
vocês viram vários deles aqui quem são
essas pessoas são pessoas que estão
criando o futuro assim como jovens
jovens crianças que precisam do apoio de
todo mundo e para isso uma das coisas
que a gente mais se orgulha é a
mobilização da sociedade para apoiar
esses empreendedores cada um deles que
que veio aqui hoje precisa do apoio de
vocês pelo apoio de investidores e
depois das agressões saúde do governo e
assim por diante
no haiti tenha de tomar a decisão de
apoiar isso daqui não é uma coisa
pequena é uma coisa transformadora para
a saúde do país
quem são essas pessoas são os principais
médicos cientistas e executivos do
einstein e também de fora que trabalham
no nosso ambiente fazendo com que esses
empreendedores dos quais eu diria uma
grande grande parte apresentou hoje aqui
possam fazer diferença
acreditamos firmemente nessa história
o empreendedorismo a adoção de
tecnologia
logicamente responsável com o paciente
no centro de tudo para fazer diferença
essa nossa história é uma história que
continua na verdade a transformação em
grande escala ela está começando
eu agradeço a atenção de todos vocês
esperamos que alguns empreendedores nos
procurem para a gente poder trabalhar
junto
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]